[Music]
I've always thought one in three kids
yes I want a boy well the Curry's wish
came true
Stefan Aisha welcomed their third child
together a healthy baby boy I would love
to have twin boys though it's not gonna
happen it doesn't cook a family but like
that would be that would be like spring
here
the MBA pro is blessed with the new
addition son Canon W Jack curry but the
proud papa is still outnumbered at home
Aisha shared a sweet pic of daughters
Riley and Ryan holding their new brother
and revealed baby Kenan came earlier
than expected on July 2nd before giving
birth to 29 year old chef was open about
her challenging pregnancy sharing she
was hospitalized five times before her
third trimester
thankfully the mama 3 seems to be
enjoying every second with her son she
posted this sweet snap cradling her
little boy captioned pierre bliss I'm so
in love
now that the Curry's have a newborn on
the roster we're sure Big Sisters Riley
and Ryan are adjusting to their new
roles ie show opened up to et about the
girls unique personalities they're
completely different my oldest is more
headstrong and adamant about about the
decisions that she made since she's
super sassy my youngest is is just so
gentle and sweet but goofy and very very
independent
[Music]